I just wanted to say
the past 11 days have been really tough
for everyone but to honor twitch I think
the best thing that we can do
is to laugh and hug each other Ellen
DeGeneres speaking on camera for the
first time since the death of Stephen
twitch boss
he was pure light as everybody in the
comments said if if you knew him you
knew that if you didn't know him you saw
it
like quite literally
kind and I think that's also why she
resonates the way that she does for so
long Ellen reflects on the tragic loss
telling fans how they can pay tribute
this holiday season
hey everybody
everyone is in pain and
trying to make sense of it and we'll
never make sense of it
and the holidays are hard I think anyway
um
but to honor twitch I think the best
thing that we can do
is to laugh and hug each other and play
games and dance and sing the comedian
hired twitch for her talk show back in
2014. over a decade ago I met someone
who changed my life and and our show and
I'm talking about you twitch come here
he was the in-house DJ until the series
wrapped earlier this year
and I know it seems hard it seems
impossible
but that's how we honor him
and hug each other and tell each other
we love each other
and let people know we're there for them
and check in on people after twitch was
found dead of a self-inflicted gunshot
wound last week Ellen shared a
heartwarming Montage to Instagram that
was my initial love for him was we just
bonded over learning to dance together
[Applause]
in the caption Ellen said all she wants
to do is remember all the love and
laughter they had together whenever he's
not here for whatever reason it's just
different I mean I I I count on him to
to look over at and make silly jokes and
and he's my pal you know he's my
sidekick because you know we have this
we have this connection so just looking
over and and he makes me laugh he really
really makes me laugh she added he
brought so much joy to my life I know he
brought joy to yours too
I know it's not a happy holiday but
he was pure light as everybody in the
comments said if if you knew him you
knew that if you didn't know him you saw
it
let's honor him
and think about him
and send love to one another
[Music]